[Musik]
hallo meine lieben
heute gibt's etwas leckeres ich bin es
ehrlich zu euch ein oh ich weiß nicht
wie man es nennt weil es gab es halt
immer nur das gab er zwischendurch mal
und dann ist es bei uns immer
klimatechnik oder cream alle belegt das
heißt halt brot oder billig mit
hackfleisch ja für mich nicht würde ich
vielleicht auf jeden fall mache ich
jetzt hier erst mal einen tag ohne hilfe
dass es kein hefeteig und ja ich bin
dabei ich bin dabei so und das ist halt
ein teig nee das hackfleisch umhüllt von
tykwers land in der pfanne gebacken mit
und o mein gott es ist so knusprig von
außen und innen kommt euch an dieses
zarte fleisch entgegen lecker gewürzt
und ist so ein rezepte sieht das bild
und jeder egal wer wird sagen oh mein
gott ich kenne das ist so lecker wie
nennt man es mal die kommentare dann
kann ich den titel ja dementsprechend um
ändern und ich fange jetzt einfach mal
an ich habe jetzt hier die
küchenmaschine ihr könnt eure hände
benutzen gar kein thema
ich habe hier mehr drin gibt da salz mit
dazu und d type besteht aus nur vier
zutaten und ich sage jetzt ich muss kurz
schlucken jetzt viel geredet und ich
habe jetzt genauso wie mehl und salz
drin lassen jetzt so langsam langsam
verkneten mit dem knethaken und gibt
dann nach und nach immer wieder ein
bisschen lauwarmes wasser rein und
verbindet sich das einfach besser wenn
das wasser warm ist dann dürft ihr ja so
ein tag erhalten wir darf nicht klebrig
sein sondern schön geschmeidig und
gerade so fest und anschließend gibt ja
auch noch ein bisschen rapsöl dazu
[Musik]
die maschine hat jetzt den teig ca 2
minuten geknetet und ich habe jetzt noch
ungefähr eine bis anderthalb minuten auf
der arbeitsfläche weitergemacht ihr
braucht nicht viel braucht auch nicht
viel wasser
ich habe euch natürlich alle genauen
mengenangaben unten in die infobox die
findet ihr neben dem titel da fragen
nämlich immer ganz viele
und genau den teig den freue mich jetzt
quasi zu einer kugel so ganz grob und
gibt ihn zurück in eine schüssel der
muss jetzt nicht wirklich aufgehen
sondern er entspannen das ist ganz
wichtig dafür gebe ich ein bisschen back
prinz break denn die schlüssel liegt dem
tag rein benetzte auch die oberfläche
damit damit er nicht austrocknet dann
den deckel drauf und circa 45 minuten
lang ruhen lassen ich zeige euch aber in
der zwischenzeit die hackfleisch füllung
[Musik]
für die hak / gelungen habe ich jetzt
hier mein fleisch in eine ausreichend
große schüssel so und da gebe ich jetzt
gewürze mit dazu ich habe ja einmal
kreuzkümmel ich für die kreuzkümmel und
hackfleisch passt einfach wie die faust
auf das auge einmal da rein
dann habe ich hier paprikapulver edelsüß
afrika pulver edelsüß und ein bisschen
chili aber noch ein bisschen weil ihr
wisst ja haben sie nicht wir sind immer
noch dann immer noch weiter wir können
das nicht mit soviel schaaf natürlich
salz mit rein und frisch gemahlenem
pfeffer und dann nämlich noch zwiebeln
dazu ich habe jetzt die zufällig rote
zwiebeln lage habt und was ganz wichtig
ist das gibt noch mal einen leckeren
trist petersilie
das habe ich auch vorab mit meinem
wiegemesser noch mal fein verarbeitet
die feiner desto besser finde ich und
dann verkneten wir das einfach aus
meinem optische ja manchmal marquis mit
handschuhen zu arbeiten und manchmal
einfach ohne soll das habe ich jetzt
auch eine minute durch geknetet und er
braucht doch kein zusätzliches
bindemittel ich nehme mir so ein
hackfleisch ball
ich bereite mich jetzt einfach mal einen
form euch das zu zeigen unser teil
konnte auch entspannen und das teilt ihr
euch jetzt einfach ein ich sage euch am
ende wie viele teiglinge ich
herausbekomme ab
[Musik]
wie kaugummis der teig also richtig
perfekte reißt euch auch nicht wie gar
nicht total perfekt das ist noch rund
alles noch denkt du weißt was du machen
normalerweise weiß haben sie nie was
sich filme erst wenn wir ganz unten
angekommen sind
aber das ist richtig er kann die sind
genau und das endergebnis eher flach und
das sind der dicke runde kugeln bissigen
schnappt ihr euch jetzt euer nudelholz
und geht da ganz vorsichtig drüber so
ich sprühe die arbeitsfläche mit back
trends verein weil der teils sonst auf
der arbeitsfläche geht und dann bekommt
ihr im risse und der teig ist aber so
geschmeidig das ja eigentlich gar keine
risse bekommen solltet also ich bereitet
alle vor und anschließend werden sie in
einer gut beschichteten pfanne mit etwas
raps oder sonnenblumenöl ausgebacken von
beiden seiten
das zeigt ein vergleich in aller ruhe
[Musik]
sonst habe ich in einer beschichteten
pfanne ein bisschen öl und hab die
mittlere stufe eingestellt lieber ein
bisschen niedriger als zu hoch weil wir
wollen jetzt dass die äußere hülle schön
knusprig wird nicht zu dunkel und dass
das fleisch gegart und das schmeckt
einfach so lecker toren unterschied ob
ihr das fleisch vorher an brett anbraten
oder ob ihr das in der halt in dieser
kruste garen lassen es ist ein
riesenunterschied schnitt noch mal ganz
ganz anders der bezirke lukas ich gebe
es hier drei oder vier stück davon rein
und dann immer wieder wenden also
wirklich immer wieder dabei bleiben
nicht weggehen und im besten falle auch
zwischendurch den deckel drauf machen
damit diese hitze wirklich innen drin
bleibt und das fleisch auch schön garen
kann damit die schützen
genau
[Musik]
also müsst euch für eine ladung schon so
acht bis zehn minuten zeit nehmen immer
wieder wenn immer wieder ein auge drauf
halten und wenn sie so aussehen dann
sind sie perfekt ziemlich sie einmal
raus und back die nächsten aus und jetzt
ist das fleisch auch richtig schön gar
und es wie schon groß aber es gab
einfach anders in diesem teil mantel
es ist ganz anders als wenn ihr das eben
direkt in der pfanne anbraten also mega
mega lecker vom außerdem sehr knusprig
[Musik]
so wenn euch das rezept jetzt sehr gut
gefallen hat genauso wie uns dann
hinterlasst main kanal auf jeden fall
ein kostenloses abo damit ihr auch die
rezepte nicht mehr verpasst ich habe
gesehen dass ganz viele die glocke nicht
aktiviert haben
wir laden ja ab und zu auch mal drittes
video die woche hoch und wenn ihr die
glocke aktiviert dann bekommt ihr das
auch mit und ansonsten würde ich sagen
an alle studenten die kein backofen
haben macht unbedingt nach sehr sehr
sehr lecker außen wie gesagt mega
knusprig und innen in diesem staate
fleisch wir haben noch ein paar stunden
dann dürfen wir endlich essen willst du
noch was sagen ich finde gerade so passt
es ganz gut ja das stimmt
das stimmt zur suppe pass ist sehr sehr
gut ansonsten außerhalb von ra man
vielleicht mal zum frühstück
schlemmerfrühstück also macht einfach
sehr gerne nach genauer zum abendessen
so ich bin ich jetzt einen wunderschönen
tag und wir sehen uns beim nächsten mal
auf die gis kitchen
[Musik]